there was solid backing for measures to
deal with Europe's migration crisis
after the recent tragedy of lamb
producer in which hundreds of mostly
African migrants perished many MEP is
called for more help at sea for
distressed migrants and for deeper
long-term policy we for you know wat de
Maga CEO / perdon a legal bolotov I this
year alone tens of thousands of migrants
have arrived off Italy Spain Greece
Cyprus Malta and Bulgaria all fleeing
poverty persecution or conflict the
opinion has to provide more
possibilities for the refugees to travel
in Europe there should be better
conditions also with financial resources
for accepting them there should be a
better and more focused help and
continuous help on the humanitarian aid
in the neighboring countries of Syria
also NEP is also called for strong
penalties for traffickers and smugglers
and for more resources for sea and land
frontier management also for help to
solve the problems at source however
many MEP sphere right-wing politicians
are using the crisis to garner support a
risky or concreto lada riva Papa least
lada riva national la popolare di adidas
troppo continue odda adesso cheap
Arcadian ochenta Forte alcuni Sodom
embrace all profile adela cigarettes I
others though point up the Europe if
it's to grow economically needs migrants
millions of them rahab bitter poison on
TV iki Konoha camilla to go to accord SE
secular casino you had to zupas
well-informed emigration ask a
demographic moylan or others 1m eps had
hoped the issue would be raised at this
week's heads of state and government
council in Brussels but it won't it's up
to the next EU presidency to deal with
the issue